what the [ __ ] was that did I [ __ ]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Windigo now if you
remember and until dawn there was a oh
hey strange creature surrounding mansion
further research are to see our team
decided to head out an investigate great
idea upon arriving we split up great
yeah they're all dead going into the
house is probably a bad idea yeah a bad
idea I'm assuming that's not a good
thing I'll dead oh I'm here okay that's
strange glowing gramma who ah I'm in the
house already I did not know this hello
ah yes oh good so if you remember in
until dawn there was such a creature
call but when to go that all the people
turned in to pick up the EMF detector by
using the e key I don't like that
tutorial limits that you use why is
there a dull staring at me that's bad
alright fine then collect ten recorders
hold cuties EMF detector and scape the
house I don't know things it's gonna be
good here we go alright so I don't know
how this game goes but it's actually a
pretty highly rated game on Steam so I
can only assume that it's got some
spooks ready for me oh ah
this room is vacant of spooks I've got
to find something else though hmm seems
to be a lot of things and stuff places
for monsters to jump out of me which I
don't like for the record but the
Windigo
and until dawn anyway was just this
creature that appeared huh well now when
humans ate other humans in the place
here oh that's the camera oh I probably
should have scouted the cameras before I
actually started going into the house
that was my mistake here okay ready then
whoa why am I looking for tape recorders
why do I care so much yeah
- Michael hey hey hey hi
I'm guessing I'm all Fine's me enough
readings in here oh those are great
pictures on the walls
oh hey stop stirred up a [ __ ] you okay I
found one - good pickup
hey oh [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you okay
alright then good taper go god I've got
an EMF
I got an M okay alright let's pick it up
some serious and breedings up there and
I want to go back up oh [ __ ] hello hi
how are you doing everybody [ __ ] off
okay alright so I'm assuming that
there's a Wendigo in desire right yeah
what what what we're doing up my god
damn it now [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
bad is the design [ __ ] god damn it oh
I'm dead I died at 914 great I found one
item and long in the short of it I did
god-awful look that thing see this
grumble in my ear I know you like to
purr away but no thank you
alright here we go back into the thick
of man interacting with doors is a
critical pain okay so can I see anything
here is there anything that's gonna help
me know maybe I could see the monster on
this thing
no okay so here we go again
it's like it's like slender but worse
every way I can't run fast I gotta be
quick and skedaddle II about it but I'm
not ready to write so let me go back up
to the kids room that seemed to work
well for me I guess kidding [ __ ] [ __ ]
you oh I'm gonna go back because
apparently I didn't pick up the goddamn
reader I'm an idiot
oh why can't I thought I got it why
can't I use it I'm pressing the button
it's working all right yeah what was
that maybe you should get the [ __ ] out
of there and maybe I'm gonna die because
I don't have a gun ever a dart okay I'm
gonna go the ways that I haven't gone
you have big spare little kid being a
little douchebag chunk right in my
crotch a little a little a little run
faster would be great
got a bit of a kink oh there's hep okay
open at-at a quick flash okay why can't
I use my goddamn EMF reading so a spoke
to do I'll clock it there really that's
where it is been here 20 minutes and
we've already heard that thing really I
saw it I saw it in the shadows down the
way I saw it oh boy I saw it kid are you
in here okay nevermind then you carry on
yes you have heard that already
Oh shitty dicks don't come in here don't
come in here you son of a [ __ ] don't
come in here I'll punch the [ __ ] out of
you in every way every one of your bones
is gonna get cried on you know you don't
want to mess with markiplier yeah I'm
gonna be okay maybe I just got to find a
few more I'm actually not that far from
it you know yeah don't whisper in me
whoo
[ __ ] okay so I just gotta go up the
other staircase and then I should be
okay if I go the back way I might be
able to get around this damn thing Oh
God hole in the floor can I jump down
great that did me a lot of good [ __ ] why
did I go down she be okay ah there we go
they seem to be okay right there dad
yeah they're dead seems like the tapes
are just appearing and random locales
strewn about the house seems like I I'm
in a lot of trouble the [ __ ] I heard
thumps sorry that's me hi okay alrighty
then we okay go down go down what the
[ __ ] is that okay don't do that don't do
that to me
okay we're fine everything's fine
everything is goddamn fine everything is
hunky-dory your daughter you'd already
dirty everything is hunky-dory in la-la
land I don't know how many I've got left
to find but it can't be too many no it
could be a whole lot however many they
want no that was bad hallway I got some
sensory feelings about that one walk
yeah I saw that god dammit [ __ ] I'm
dusty Dale as hard as I can which offers
two derelict Jews [ __ ] I'm not going to
get that right now over the kids later
I've got an appointment
[Applause]
well [ __ ] anytime a sack of piss oh
there is got it nailed it nailed it you
keep your Jeff Jeff Jeff gave to me to
give it to me we got I told one of you
here yeah get that okay please Debbie
I was I mean wait
there's a brother there oh the problem
run vastly I'm staying here all night
she jumps so you have to hit shift you
can't just hold shift down you got to
hit it run [ __ ] [ __ ] dicks okay that
makes sense I guess rule will real I
don't like that like that we're weird
right hey whoa oh yeah hey
Yeti Windigo ho [ __ ] go go go go go
yeah I'm damn dogs a million ways I'm
dead I'm dead I'm trying to skedaddle my
skedaddle button is a little broken
trying to skedaddle
Oh skedaddle eNOS skedaddle I think I
got away because I don't know how I
don't know why I think I did and that's
good I guess
you know there's like every Asian women
urban legend surrounding this thing
right
what the heck was that no no no no I've
been eating thugs they didn't believe
because it didn't believe okay so where
is he
I should oh I see him he's in where the
[ __ ] is that
but I see a red dot of there oh so I can
see ah all right so he's over there
that's the second bedroom so that's
where he is right now so if I can look
for a red ooh oh wait why no you late
lied to me they lied to me you lied to
me you lied to me
oh [ __ ] is it a bad idea remember never
remember remember that's bad
did you get so he's getting a lot more
active that's exactly love [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm trying I'm spamming the Run
button seven of ten almost there yeah I
got get that why do I need the report
what the [ __ ] with that Oh No thank you
work you know that you know that you
know that you know that you know that
you good know that you rawr rawr rawr
rawr no no no no yeah
fire [ __ ] what the [ __ ] why do I need
this I could just go away I could just
go home at any moment that'd be fun and
fine and cool oh that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] I can't find these
goddamn things is that oh god damn it
here can I get this axe yeah it's all
[ __ ] alright
yeah [ __ ] I'm dead I think I saw it
behind me but I don't think that's gonna
help me [ __ ] [ __ ] oh go go [ __ ] go
[ __ ] go [ __ ] go okay we're you a
junior
we got drywall what the [ __ ] that's not
fair that's not fair that's not fair not
fair not fair not fair not fair not fair
not fair not fair not fair
[ __ ] run system is on not fair
they're not they're not they're not
they're not fair not fair not fair not
fair not fair okay all right not fair
not fair
okay so anyway that is going to go I'm
not gonna do that again cuz then
is the opposite of fair so I found eight
of ten I don't know what happens when
you get all ten I'm assuming something
along the lines of hey you won good job
go get an ice cream or something like
that so let me know what you think of
this if you want plates for yourself
it's available on Steam right now and my
voice needs a little bit of a break but
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of it down
in the comments below and as always over
see you in the next bye
[Music]